[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
que se passe-t-il entre Emmanuel Macron
et Olaf scholls les relations entre
Paris et Berlin sont fraîches pour
preuve l'annulation du Conseil des
ministres franco-allemand à
Fontainebleau transformé en un déjeuner
à l'Elysée un déjeuner sans déclaration
ni conférence de presse hasard du
calendrier le gouvernement allemand
approuve aujourd'hui une prise de
participation par la société chinoise
Cosco dans l'un des trois terminaux de
la société exploitante du port de
Hambourg les divergences entre la France
et l'Allemagne sont palpables dans
l'énergie et dans la défense mais est-ce
plus profond la France met en garde
l'Allemagne contre son isolement Berlin
dégaine un plan de relance de 200
milliards d'euros et annonce un
déplacement à Pékin où on est ce couple
franco-allemand est-il en crise est-il
au bord de la rupture la guerre en
Ukraine a-t-elle bouleversé profondément
cette relation entre Paris et Berlin le
tandem franco-allemand est-il toujours
la locomotive de l'Europe et finalement
de quelle Europe par le ton et bien on
en débat avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés madame
Anne-Sophie altif bonsoir vous êtes
enseignante en économie à la Sorbonne et
chef économiste au cabinet de conseil
BDO France bienvenue à vous en face de
vous pierre lelouchoir ancien député
secrétaire d'État chargé des affaires
européennes c'est entre 2009 et 2010
puis du commerce extérieur c'était donc
au sein du gouvernement François Fillon
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être avec nous
également avec nous Alexandre robinet
Borgomano bonsoir conseiller Allemagne à
l'Institut Montaigne bienvenue dans le
débat
Emmanuel Macron et olafchaul sont donc
déjeunés ensemble un déjeuner qui a pris
donc la place de ce fameux Conseil des
ministres conseils Conseils des
ministres de Fontainebleau qui a été
annulée pas de conférence de presse pas
de déclaration officielle à l'issue de
ce déjeuner mais l'Élysée a salué une
réunion très constructive je cite avec
l'installation de groupe de travail on
va écouter Olivier Véran le porte-parole
de l'Élysée c'était juste avant le
déjeuner ce moteur franco-allemand nous
comptons bien continuer de le faire
vivre et la visite du chancelier
allemand en ce moment même à l'Élysée
qui rencontrera le président de la
République attestent de cette amitié
bien vivante et de notre volonté
d'avancer ensemble et parfois d'être
capable de franchir les difficultés du
temps et du moment quand les priorités
d'un pays ne sont pas forcément de
convergent pas forcément avec les
priorités de l'autre et bien la force du
couple franco-allemand c'est d'être
toujours capable de s'entendre et de
tirer l'ensemble de l'Europe vers le
haut et on va écouter Emmanuel Macron
c'était la semaine dernière juste avant
le Conseil européen
je pense que ce n'est pas bon ni pour
l'Allemagne ni pour l'Europe quel
s'isole et donc il est important que sur
une des propositions qui font l'objet
d'un assez large consensus on puisse
trouver une unanimité pierre Lelouche
commence par vous parce que vous étiez
aux affaires vous typiquement à ce poste
franco-allemand si je puis dire du temps
de Nicolas Sarkozy de François Fillon
est-ce qu'il est en panne selon vous ce
couple franco-allemand c'est assez
inédit ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
c'est plus qu'une panne madame nous
sommes en train de vivre un tournant
dans l'histoire de l'Europe accélérée
par la guerre en Ukraine mais
moi je sors un papier la semaine
prochaine là-dessus qui s'appelle le
retour de la question allemande la
question allemande a dominé l'histoire
de l'Europe tout au long du 19e siècle
et une bonne partie de du siècle passé
jusqu'en 1945 elle a été
elle a eu des conséquences extrêmement
violentes sur le continent plusieurs
dizaines de millions de morts plusieurs
guerres avec la France 3 de suite
et elle a été réglée
en 1945 par la division de l'Allemagne
une moitié de l'Allemagne était sous
contrôle soviétique une autre moitié
c'est retrouver
menotté à l'intérieur de
l'OTAN d'abord au moment où sont
réarmement à partir de 1954 et puis
l'Union européenne donc la question
allemande
elle était sous contrôle le secrétaire
le premier secrétaire général de
l'automne
pour comprendre le coup franc en
allemand faut comprendre que la base
stratégique de l'Europe était d'abord
fondée sur cette sur la résolution de la
question allemande le premier secrétaire
général de l'OTAN lors des semait avait
cette formule à quoi servait le temps
les Américains ont les fait venir et les
Allemands on les tient sous contrôle et
ça c'est le régime qui a présidé pendant
toutes les années de la guerre froide et
qui a permis la réconciliation
franco-allemande
le traité de l'Élysée en 63 mais sans la
dimension militaire dont les Allemands
ne voulaient pas parce que pour eux et
avec l'Alliance atlantique et ça a tenu
jusqu'à la chute du Mur le 9 novembre 89
depuis
et je rappelle cette histoire parce que
quand le mur est tombé aussi bien
François Mitterrand que Maggie saturd ne
voulait pas là une signification
allemande parce qu'ils avaient
instinctivement compris que la
réunification de l'Allemagne plus son
poids économique allait se faire au
détriment du poids de l'Angleterre et de
la France et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe à présent la guerre en Ukraine a
été un accélérateur du retour de la
puissance allemande tous azimuts au
centre de l'Europe avec une vocation non
seulement économique mais aussi
militaire et du coup
l'illusion française qui était que cette
Europe n'était pensable est possible que
parce qu'il y avait eu cette
réconciliation à l'époque de Gaulle à No
qu'il y avait ce fameux couple
l'expression qui n'est jamais employée
côté allemand d'ailleurs jamais
justement
pour comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui entre la France et
l'Allemagne pour comprendre que la
question allemande est de retour que
l'Allemagne va
occuper un
poids un rose
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir un pays qui
va être
leader économique et stratégique qui se
positionne comme la première armée
d'Europe et c'est en train de tout
changer
et contrairement à ce que dit Monsieur
Macron
c'est pas l'Allemagne qui est isolé
c'est la France qui devient isolée dans
cette dans cette configuration vous êtes
d'accord Alexandre Binet bourgomano
alors c'est vrai que les Allemands ne
parlent jamais de couple franco-allemand
ça c'était une expression française où
il parle plutôt de Tandem pourquoi ils
ne veulent pas vraiment y mettre de la
fête vous êtes d'accord avec ce que je
viens de dire justement pierre Lelouch
parce que cette mise en perspective
historique est extrêmement intéressante
et qu'elle traduit un des problèmes de
la relation franco-allemande actuelle
qui du côté français réside dans le fait
qu'on est encore des réflexes datant de
1945 ou des années 40 et que il paraît
difficile de construire une relation de
confiance une relation de couple lorsque
on a ces a priori bellicistes ou lorsque
l'on voit encore l'Allemagne
d'aujourd'hui qui s'est radicalement
transformé au cours du de 50 dernières
années mais aussi durant le quinquennat
d'Angela Merkel durant les 15 années de
16 années de pouvoir de tanguer la
Merkel et que donc je pense qu'il serait
intéressant donc je vais vous parler de
la priori belliciste de non je décris
juste un anti germanisme qui est
l'attend dans la société française
quand vous parlez de l'Allemagne pour
rappel rappeler que maintenir la donne
était l'objectif de la construction
européenne ça me paraît être un pré
supposé ou un point de départ un peu
difficile pour construire une relation
constructive après je suis d'accord avec
vous la relation franco-allemande
aujourd'hui elle est fragilisée et le
grand problème de la France aujourd'hui
c'est l'affirmation de l'Allemagne comme
puissance centrale au cœur du continent
elle était déjà depuis longtemps une
puissance économique majeure désormais
elle assume un rôle géopolitique un rôle
géostratégique mais c'est ce qu'on lui
demande depuis une dizaine d'années ça
fait 10 ans qu'on reproche à l'Allemagne
de pas investir suffisamment dans sa
défense donc j'en ai l'impression que
quoi que l'Allemagne fasse
suscitera toujours les critiques de ses
partenaires et au premier rang les
critiques de la France Anne-Sophie Asfix
on a vu en tout cas que concrètement il
y avait des des divergences entre
l'Allemagne et la France sur des points
précis en l'occurrence sur l'énergie
alors on reproche à l'Allemagne d'avoir
fait cavalier seul avec son plan de
relance de 200 milliards d'euros face à
la crise énergétique les verres
Allemands attaquent le nucléaire
français est-ce effectivement vous êtes
d'accord c'est plutôt l'Allemagne qui
s'isole ou comme le dit Emmanuel Macron
c'est plutôt la France qui s'isole
plutôt l'Allemagne qui s'isole et moi
c'est vrai que je me baserais plutôt sur
les faits et surtout les faits
économiques qu'est-ce qui se passe et
d'ailleurs c'est assez étonnant puisque
c'est aussi ce que regarde les analyses
en Allemagne si on est aujourd'hui dans
cette situation c'est uniquement en
raison de la politique gandela Merkel
qui a refusé de faire l'Europe de
l'énergie depuis plus de 10 ans et
d'ailleurs elle a été très critiquée en
Allemagne par rapport à ça si on a eu
aucune diversification du mix
énergétique pendant plus de 10 ans c'est
uniquement en raison de la position
allemande je rappelle de 60% de
dépendance à la Russie alors que de
l'autre côté la Chine a totalement
diversifié n'a pas plus de 10% d'un
fournisseur étranger qu'il fournit
l'énergie et les États-Unis sont
complètement autosuffisants donc ça
c'est la première chose et c'est la même
chose sur l'Europe du numérique de la
santé on l'a vu avec le covid l'idée
c'était toujours de faire cavalier seul
avant d'avoir une vision européenne donc
moi c'est vrai que quand on regarde
vraiment l'analyse économique et en tout
cas on regarde les chiffres il y a
vraiment toujours l'idée de l'Allemagne
de défendre en premier ses intérêts on
l'a vu à même quand il y a eu la crise
du commerce
on ne pense qu'à soi on pense qu'à ses
intérêts mais juste pour finir sur les
aspects économiques et là c'est vrai que
je serai tout à fait en désaccord avec
vous quand vous regardez les faits
l'Allemagne est en récession l'année
prochaine l'Allemagne non le reste de la
zone euro non qu'est-ce qui se passe au
niveau aussi économique c'est un des
pays qui perd chaque année énormément
d'employés enfin de de salariés sur son
marché du travail à cause du
vieillissement et tout son modèle a été
fait sur des excédents commerciaux
colossaux qui commencent à se tasser
puisque la machine-outil et le virement
de la révolution on va dire écologique
dans l'automobile a été raté donc
économiquement quand vous regardez sur
10 20 ans en prospective ce qui va se
passer sur l'Allemagne c'est plutôt un
pays qui est beaucoup plus affaibli par
rapport à ses partenaires européens donc
plutôt affaibli Alexandre je vais vous
faire réagir au pire Lelouch mais
lorsque est-ce que c'est pas un peu la
vieille rengaine qu'on entend quand même
en France depuis un moment c'est à dire
là l'Allemagne qui
ses partenaires enfin qui agit
économiquement contre ses partenaires là
encore c'est le caractère paradoxal des
critiques qu'on
impose à l'Allemagne aujourd'hui on lui
reprochait pendant des dizaines d'années
de pas investir suffisamment de pas être
suffisamment keynésien de pas
suffisamment soutenir l'économie par
l'investissement public parce que nous
apprend aujourd'hui c'est qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'une vraie politique keynésienne
c'est pas une politique qui consiste à
ajouter toujours de l'argent public dans
les circuits économiques c'est une
politique avant tout contracyclique qui
consiste à constituer des excédents en
période d'expansion pour pouvoir les
réinjecter dans l'économie lorsqu'on
entre période de récession et là
l'Allemagne après ces années de
stabilité de prospérité entre dans une
période de turbulence absolument inédite
et elle a la marge de manœuvre
budgétaire dont elle a besoin pour
sauver son économie pierre Lelouch
excuse moi j'aimerais réagir dans le
semestre européen normalement des flash
chaque pays européen ne doit pas avoir
plus de 8% donc du PIB en termes
d'excédent commerciaux et c'est pareil
pour la dette publique et un certain
nombre de critères l'Allemagne il a
absolument jamais respecté et le premier
à justement essayer de sanctionner les
autres pays quand il y a des problèmes
dans des vêtements aujourd'hui vous
dites oui ils font de l'investissement
public l'investissement public dans la
défense à qui ils achètent dans le
secteur de la défense ils achètent pas
aux Français on est quand même très bon
dans le dans la défense et on vend quand
même beaucoup de produits il les
achètent aux Américains posez-vous la
question si les Chinois les Américains
feraient la même chose pierre Lelouche
vous répondez s'il vous plaît Emmanuel
Macron a écrit enfin répondu à une
interview aux échos l'Allemagne est à un
moment de changement de modèle dont il
ne faut pas sous-estimer le caractère
déstabilisateur est-ce que c'est ça la
clé
oui encore une fois
moi j'étais
choqué que vous preniez une analyse
historique pour quelque chose
d'anti-allemand ce qui est complètement
absurde
c'est le réflexe d'aveuglement qui est
le vôtre c'est ça qui me gêne il y a une
histoire
l'Allemagne d'aujourd'hui c'est le
produit de cette histoire alors que
votre génération ne veulent pas il la
regarder en face c'est un problème mais
très très connu la France avec
conscience de la nécessité d'une
réconciliation
sortir votre votre laïus
nous sommes nous sommes dans un nous
sommes dans un moment tournant c'est pas
depuis hier matin que que l'Allemagne a
une politique
unilatéraliste quand c'est son intérêt
ça a toujours été comme ça quand de
Gaulle lui a proposé dans les années 50
au moment du plan Fouché 62 63 de faire
une union politique l'Allemagne n'a
jamais voulu parce que le devenir
politique et stratégique de l'Allemagne
c'était l'Alliance atlantique et
uniquement l'Alliance atlantique donc
tous les projets français d'Europe de la
défense ont capoté par la guerre froide
après la guerre froide tu rappelles que
le débit de la guerre de Yougoslavie
c'est la reconnaissance unilatérale par
l'Allemagne en demandant à personne de
l'indépendance de la Croatie c'est ça
qui me le fait aux poudres et on a la
guerre de ygoslavie quand ensuite
Mitterrand échange
la stabilité le coût franco-allemand et
Maastricht on fabrique une monnaie
commune l'euro mais aux conditions de
l'Allemagne avec les critères imposés
par la par la bonne de je parle quand il
a fallu et j'y étais au gouvernement à
l'époque sauvé la Grèce en 2008 nous
avons eu les plus grandes difficultés à
faire en sorte que là que l'Allemagne
participe à n'en voulait pas que pour
elle l'Europe c'était pas une économie
de transfert on est des pas les pays
qu'ils appellent du Club Med dont nous
donc on est dans une dans une stratégie
qui est qui est en effet très solitaire
la politique l'Allemagne le succès de
l'Allemagne et je rappelle que avant la
guerre d'Ukraine regardez ça en tête et
j'ai été au commerce extérieur le
déficit du commerce extérieur de la
France aujourd'hui c'est de l'ordre de
100 milliards qu'il considérable tandis
que l'Allemagne avant l'Ukraine c'était
plus de 150 milliards c'est à dire qu'on
a un delta de 350 milliards qui
correspond à 18 points de PIB français
si vous dire alors sur quoi était basé
ce modèle allemand et c'est ça qui est
important et c'est ça que fait sauter là
la guerre en Ukraine il est défendu sur
deux choses la drogue du gaz russe à bas
prix et l'exportation massive des
automobiles en Chine c'est ça le modèle
allemand plus 0 défense pas de dépenses
en défense la guerre entre crainte
change tout ça parce que tout d'un coup
le sens comment parce qu'on a
l'impression à vous entendre si on est
dans la continuité
non pas du tout il y a une affirmation
maintenant du leadership allemand une
tentative de leadership politique sur
une Europe qu'elle veut élargir à 8 ou
10 pays en plus et notamment tous les
pays des Balkans avec un mode de
fonctionnement à l'Allemand c'est à dire
à la majorité à la majorité qui devrait
donc permettre à l'Allemagne avec ses
confettis de petits États autour de
maintenir sa suprématie exactement comme
l'avait prévu Jacques Bainville au
lendemain du traité de Versailles donc
on revient à cette même équation un pays
dominant un confettis de pays de plus
petit autour qui dépendent naturellement
de la couverture américaine c'est les
Baltes c'est les Polonais et l'Allemagne
s'impose et du coup la forme mais c'est
beaucoup plus grave que ça la France
elle est éjectée de ce système
littéralement mais bien entendu parce
que regardez cette histoire de défense
antimissiles avec 14 pays de l'OTAN ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que tous les
programmes de défense européenne vendue
par la France sont mis sous le boisseau
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne développe depuis
plusieurs années une politique spatiale
absolument anti Ariane et anti-esa avec
ses profs financements tous les
programmes d'armement
franco-allemand que je connais et j'y ai
travaillé sont tous à l'arrêt qu'il
s'agissent du char rail métal
s'appelle Panther au revoir Nexter et le
char franco-allemand qui s'agisse de
l'avion de patrouille maritime qui
devait remplacer les Atlantiques et les
Orions on achète
américains
font que les Berlinois nous regardent
avec commisération comme des gens pas
très sérieux et pour eux le jeu n'est
pas là le jeu c'est l'Amérique pour la
défense c'est l'Europe élargie et c'est
une nouvelle relation avec la Chine à
laquelle il travaille puisque Scholt va
en Allemagne dans 15 jours maintenant si
on veut pas comprendre ça monsieur libre
à vous mais après
on est d'accord avec vous le problème
dans la relation franco-allemand c'est
qu'il faut arrêter de regarder la paille
dans l'oeil du voisin et regarder enfin
notre et cessez de penser que
l'Allemagne est la cause de notre
déclassement
ne nous regarde plus comme un partenaire
crédible parce qu'on a jamais tenir
notre organisme
en termes de développement des énergies
renouvelables également mais maintenant
pour revenir à votre question sur la
recomposition du modèle allemand qui a
des effets déstabilisateur à la fois sur
la relation franco-allemande mais
également sur la relation que
l'Allemagne entre tient avec ses autres
partenaires européens ce modèle vous
l'avez évoqué reposé sur trois éléments
confiés la défense aux États-Unis sans
investir dans sa défense être dépendant
du gaz russe et être dépendant de la
Chine pour ses exportations aujourd'hui
sur les questions du gaz russe elle se
trouve dans une position extrêmement
fragilisée sur les questions
de gaz russe parce qu'elle était très
dépendante elle est toujours d'ailleurs
je rappelle que l'Allemagne a fait
construire Nord Stream 2 après
l'annexion de la Crimée c'est vous dire
à quel point les Allemands jusqu'au bout
et l'Allemagne avait beaucoup de gaz
c'était votre expression tout à fait
papillon monsieur moi j'ai eu en train
de mourir j'ai eu devant moi entendez
devant moi lors d'un dîner avec la
chancelière Angela Merkel François
Fillon à mes côtés Angela Merkel et son
ministre à côté d'elle en 2011 elle est
en train de nous dire moi j'arrête le
nucléaire
et toi François tu vas fermer Fessenheim
je l'ai entendu de mes oreilles bon et
j'ai dû dire à Madame la chancelière que
la France était encore à l'État
souverain mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
derrière les verres français ont embrayé
sur le laïus des vers allemand et on a
abouti à la décision de François
Hollande d'annoncer la fermeture de 14
centrales nucléaires alors que c'était
notre seul avantage
sous la pression de la politique
allemande la pression allemande et de
Angela Merkel nous avons fermé
Fessenheim absolument en plus avec un
accord interne entre les socialistes et
les Verts au moment des législatives
c'est un scandale absolu ce qui s'est
passé on est quand même parce qu'il faut
quand même le dire en effet ils sont
excessivement fragilités et fragilisés
aujourd'hui s'ils ont cette nouvelle
politique c'est parce que justement ils
ont fait une erreur gravissime de
politique économique et énergétique qui
les fragile je rappelle qu'ils ont
beaucoup plus d'inflation que nous et
que ce n'est pas que la question
pour financer leurs entreprises et payer
leurs notes au partenaires européens
par rapport juste pour finir par rapport
à ça il faut le dire bien sûr qu'il y a
une volonté par rapport à la Chine on
l'a dit la défense avec les États-Unis
et cetera mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a il y
a surtout une logique de bloc
aujourd'hui qui existe qui font qui a le
bloc américain le bloc chinois et que
l'Allemagne refuse de jouer la carte de
l'Europe pour être dans ce bloc de
régionalisation pourquoi parce que on
parle pas d'aujourd'hui on parle dans
10-15 ans le pays n'est pas sûr demain
d'être toujours le leader dans la
transition numérique dans la transition
écologique et dans tout ce qui faisait
sa puissance donc en effet l'Allemagne
ne veut pas être dans une Europe où il
le pays ne domine plus le jeu ou ne peut
plus justement imposer son agenda
politique et préfère en effet où se
rajouter se rapprocher des pays baltes
ou de dire on reste sous le jour
américain pour la défense pour ne pas
jouer la carte de l'Europe et c'est ça
le sujet de pas aujourd'hui mais dans
10-15 ans et c'est ça aujourd'hui qui se
joue parce que dans 10-15 ans la
politique des blocs sera faite et
l'Allemagne aujourd'hui l'empêche ce qui
est intéressant c'est que
quand on se décrit cette situation qui
est compliquée en Allemagne vous avez
raison il est très difficile de savoir
ce que les Allemands vont faire de leur
puissance aujourd'hui ils sont en mode
survie ils ont décidé de faire le double
room là pour sauver leurs entreprises
ces entreprises là vont pouvoir payer
leur note d'électricité pas les nôtres
et il va se traduire ça va se traduire
par un véritable cannibalisme industriel
les boîtes vont fermer dans les autres
pays et de forcer délocaliser dans les
endroits où l'énergie est pas chère par
exemple aux États-Unis elles vont
pouvoir survivre en Allemagne donc ce
qui est en train de jouer en Allemagne
alors que le prix
parce qu'ils ont l'argent
nous nous sommes percus de dettes si
vous additionnez la dette publique
française la dette privée et celle des
ménages on arrive à 350% du PIB vous
m'entendez tous les pays européens
la dette elle est possédée par les
Japonais
par des fonds de pension étrangers nous
sommes dans une phase de grande
vulnérables et c'est ça qui explique à
l'issue d'un déjeuner comme celui-là qui
est qui est fait pour sauver les
apparences moi j'ai eu à organiser des
conseils des ministres globalement je
sais ce que c'est donc quand c'est
annulé c'est lourd le chancelier vient
essayer de calmer le jeu mais derrière
on va pas devant les journalistes parce
que les désaccords de fond sur l'espace
sur les armes sur le défense
anti-missile sur le prix du gaz sur
l'achat commun de gaz tout ça n'est pas
réglé pour ça c'est que l'Allemagne elle
a sa stratégie elle va s'y tenir et que
nous à côté on va avoir beaucoup de mal
à fabriquer une coalition qui est
capable de dire non c'est ça le sujet
alors
c'est toujours la même chose c'était le
cas avec la Grèce vous l'avez dit avec
le covid et à chaque fois on ne veut pas
y aller on fait cavalier seul il faut
quand même rappeler que la zone euro on
a la même monnaie et que les premiers
partenaires commerciaux de l'Allemagne
ça reste quand même pour l'instant
l'Europe donc si tous ces partenaires
commerciaux ont la même monnaie vont
très mal on peut pas non plus
non mais là je parle de l'ensemble
économique avec e-commerce l'Allemagne
et nous avons surtout la même monnaie
donc s'il commence à avoir des problèmes
de stabilité là tout d'un coup
l'Allemagne décide en effet de ce rappel
qu'elle est européenne mais c'est
toujours au dernier du Rubicon Alexandre
robinet bourgomano juste elle se coupe
sur franco-allemand c'est un mythe
finalement
certains qualifices chimère moi je pense
que le président français l'un des
derniers à croire encore dans ce couple
franco-allemand il a raison d'y croire
puisque ce couple il a montré qu'il
pouvait être fait con pas juste en
créant l'Union européenne mais aussi en
mettant en place ce plan de relance de
750 milliards d'euros pour permettre aux
économies européennes de faire face à la
crise
covidalisation des dettes aussi non non
c'était vraiment une avancée colossale
ce plan de relance ce plan de relance
historique et en attendant ça louper
rapidement et donc je crois que
aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît cet axe franco-allemand
il est indépassable pour construire une
Europe plus souveraine et plus unie dans
un monde et pas moi je vous dis que vous
êtes retardé d'un métro parce que le
l'axe franco-allemand c'était le
l'histoire d'avant nous sommes
maintenant dans un monde complètement
différent une Europe qui a complètement
changé avec cette guerre avec un poids
beaucoup plus grand des pays de l'Est et
des pays
donc le rôle de la France dans cette
histoire pour équilibrer l'ensemble peut
être beaucoup plus complexe je suis pas
certain que nécessairement on peut
s'accrocher
à l'Institut très proche du président
Macron moi j'aime bien le Président j'ai
rien contre lui et enfin je veux dire on
va pas continuer à ressasser les
histoires qui tiennent pas la route la
souveraineté européenne il en reste quoi
la défense européenne il en reste quoi
non alors
je voudrais qu'on avance un peu dans le
débat avec justement une déclaration
européenne sur le fait qu'on serait plus
du tout aligné en franco-allemand je
pense qu'il est là une un mythe ou une
illusion on n'a jamais été aussi aligné
sur les concepts de souveraineté
européenne il y a trois quatre ans dès
que la France parlait de d'autonomie
stratégique la l'héritière de la
chancelière parler d'illusions
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez le
discours qui a prononcé Olaf Scholt
c'est à Prague quand vous regardez son
discours sur le changement d'époque il y
a la vraie volonté de construire une
Europe de la défense comme complément au
renforcement du pilier européen de
l'OTAN et ce qu'on va pourquoi on est
toujours en train de d'opposer les il
peut très bien y avoir des projets de
coopération entre la France et
l'Allemagne ou entre un petit groupe
d'État n’empêche pas l'Allemagne
d'avancer sur d'autres projets
complémentaires avec les États d'Europe
centrale et orientale justement vous
parliez de ce discours de Prague d'olive
on va écouter un extrait de ce discours
c'était le 29 août dernier olafials
je m'engage pour l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne au pays des Balkans
occidentaux de l'Ukraine de la Moldavie
et en perspective de la Géorgie
en Europe une Union européenne de 30 ou
36 États mais qui sera différent de
notre union actuelle
c'est vrai que ça bascule vers l'Est
c'était évident enfin je veux dire c'est
que d'aller prétendre que le discours de
Prague c'est pareil que le discours de
la Sorbonne de Macron c'est ne rien
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer il y avait dans la dans le
discours de Macron la volonté de
poursuivre dans le sillon tracé depuis
longtemps par par deux Gaules puis
Pompidou puis Giscard Mitterrand l'idée
de bâtir autour du tandem
franco-allemand une union politique qui
puisse faire en sorte que l'Europe
existe entre les États-Unis la Russie et
la Chine c'était ça l'objectif de la
diplomatie française que moi-même j'ai
porté j'ai soutenu bon force est de
constater que pour que ça marche il
fallait que la France et l'Allemagne
soient à peu près à parité économique or
le décrochage depuis 15 ou 20 ans a été
colossale j'ai rappelé les chiffres du
commerce extérieur que moi j'ai vécu
comme une punition pourquoi parce qu'on
m'avait plus rien avant c'est la
désindustrialisation de la France qui
fait que le commerce extérieur de la
France s'est effondré tandis que
l'Allemagne elle de façon extrêmement
précise à ces exportations à partir du
moment où vous avez un tel différentiel
le fait que nous soyons une puissance
nucléaire et plus virile militairement
ne compensez plus là
aujourd'hui si vous voulez dans ce
rapport au moment où schols dit moi je
mets 100 milliards pour réarmer
l'Allemagne et je serai la première
armée d'Europe ce couple il continue à
se dégrader encore plus alors que
l'Europe se décale vers l'est et nous à
l'autre bout du continent qu'est-ce qui
nous reste nous restait espagnol les
Portugais et éventuellement les Italiens
dans une Europe que Scholtz
reconstruit comme étant le repas
allemande qui a toujours existé monsieur
à partir du 19e siècle avec les
confettis de petits États autour que
personne venait équilibrer retour de la
question allemande vous devrez relire
Jacques Bainville monsieur ça vous serez
vraiment utile et puis allez-y
Anne-Sophie
européenne il faut le dire que là aussi
ça a toujours été guidé par les intérêts
allemands et le fait la Pologne et la
Roumanie sont venus en fait dans
l'Europe c'était une stratégie
industrielle qui était avouée d'avoir
des pays qui ont un fort niveau
d'éducation de fort coup de main
d'oeuvre on a pu et l'Allemagne à
délocaliser tout ce qui était à très
faible valeur ajoutée dans ces pays-là
et a pu garder ce qui était à Fort
valeur ajoutée dans son pays pour monter
en gamme et donc c'est grâce à cette
intégration européenne qu'elle a pu
faire son modèle industriel le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en effet c'est la
voiture et c'est la machine multi
qu'elle a vendu partout dans le monde
parce qu'il y avait de la
réindustrialisation et du développement
au niveau des pays émergents demain on
est beaucoup plus dans une
serviceisation de l'économie ou
normalement le modèle économique quand
vous faites les projections à 10-15 ans
de l'Allemagne par rapport à son
positionnement productif et beaucoup
moins favorable dans un pays où la
consommation intérieure ne fonctionne
pas on a vu baisse de TVA pendant le
covid on réinjecte toujours de l'argent
dans l'économie les Allemands ne
consomment pas donc vraiment ce qui fait
leur économie c'est vraiment les
exportations et le commerce ils n'ont
pas de soupapes que nous par rapport à
la consommation
juste c'est très important parce que
aujourd'hui c'est la première puissance
mais dans 10-15 ans ils ne sont ils ne
savent si le son donc c'est vrai que de
diversifier d'avoir d'autres parts oui
ils travaillent mais comme nous comme
d'autres et donc le fait de diversifier
en effet se décaler vers l'Est comme ils
l'ont fait avant avec la Pologne et la
Roumanie c'est de se donner un autre cap
un autre marché et la possibilité de
rester une puissance industrielle qui
aujourd'hui est quand même assez impacté
attendez alexandreville
en Allemagne je pense que il y a plein
de pays qui auront besoin d'industrie et
franchement ce que produisent des
Allemands malheureusement peut payer le
fond en dehors peut-être de l'Italie sur
les marchés Unity donc il reste
extrêmement
compétitifs
regardez où vont les investissements
high tech moi je constate le gros des
investissements a complètement passé
l'investissement dans toutes les
justement le numéro que vous avez déjà
essayé d'avoir le 5G en Allemagne
ce domaine ils sont
les investissements américains ils vont
d'abord en Allemagne une scène
importante pour le développement des
startups il faut le reconnaître aussi
quelle est la marge de manœuvre de la
France Alexandre Binet Borgomano face à
cette situation dont on parle à ce
germanifer et à se décalage à ce c'est
se basculement vers l'Est de l'Europe en
tout cas le souhait que l'Allemagne de
cette Europe que souhaite l'Allemagne si
on veut rétablir la relation
franco-allemande de façon équilibrée je
pense que là je rejoins monsieur le
ministre il faut nous-mêmes parvenir à
rétablir notre crédibilité comme
partenaire comme partenaire économique
et comme partenaire capable de de faire
avancer des projets concrets on a évoqué
rapidement le projet de de char
franco-allemand du futur d'avions de
combat franco-allemand et il faut que
ces projets aboutissent je comprends pas
pourquoi ils sont bloqués ces projets le
président
de la défense ont rappelé leur tout de
tout leur grand discours que ces projets
étaient prioritaires c'est visiblement
au niveau des industriels il y a un
blocage et c'est blocage doivent être
levés pour faire de nouveau de la France
un partenaire qui a envie d'avancer avec
l'Allemagne et qui démontre qu'il a
envie d'avancer avec l'Allemagne
casseraient les dossiers en fait
quel dossier sur lesquels sont les
dossiers sur lesquels ils pourraient
coopérer la France et l'Allemagne parce
que vous écoutez on n'a plus aucun tous
les il faut là aussi garder le
l'histoire en tête le chat
franco-allemand il a commencé sous
Michel Debré et Frans il est jamais été
construit pourquoi est-ce qu'il a jamais
été construit parce que les Allemands
après la guerre ils avaient gardé leur
industrie des chats ils faisaient les
meilleurs chats de combat de la deuxième
guerre mondiale avec le tigre et le
panthère le panthère qui renaît
aujourd'hui chez Rennes métal le même le
même nom d'accord sur l'aéronautique
c'était un peu différent parce qu'après
la guerre on leur a cassé leur industrie
aéronautique alors qu'ils avaient
inventé les fusées et le premier avion à
réaction qui s'appelait le message
Schmidt 262
on leur a interdit de faire ça et donc
l'industrie aéronautique française a
repris le leadership en Europe parce
qu'on nous avait nous aussi on savait
faire les avions avant guerre et on a
construit spatial on a construit cette
coopération franco-allemande de pierre
à chaque fois qu'on a vu un programme et
j'ai bien croyez moi je connais bien ces
sujets à chaque fois que les projets ont
prospéré c'était dans des endroits où
les Américains les Allemands pouvaient
récupérer de la technologie par exemple
dans l'aéronautique dans les chars on
n'a jamais rien fait dans l'aéronautique
on a fait un peu un peu dans les
hélicoptères aussi mais regardez ce qui
s'est passé depuis il s'est passé que
airbus est progressivement passé sous
direction allemande et que la partie
défense d'Airbus est située à Munich est
devenu entièrement allemande c'est elle
qui travaille sur le Tornado c'est elle
qui fabrique aujourd'hui
les l'avions de combat du futur n'ont
pas avec la France veut travailler avec
les Américains les drones et tout le
reste tout ça c'est la partie Airbus
militaire qui est devenu très très
puissante et qui est hors France de même
sur les espaces ce qui s'est passé de
façon très intéressante toute cette
dernière année c'est que alors que nous
avons raté le virage Elon Musk etc les
Landes les lanceurs chez Ariane à cause
de la pesanteur et du manque d'argent
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les Allemands
ils ont financé à fond leur propre
start-up qui fabriquent des lanceurs
privés très efficace
idem pour les satellites
un rayon X enfin je partage
que font les Allemands
en matière de char il y aura pas de char
franco-allemand en matière d'avion de
combat ils ne veulent pas que la France
conserve un leadership sur les avions de
combat alors que nous on sait les faire
donc il y aura pas d'avion
de surveillance militaire naval et bien
ils ont choisi d'acheter des Orions
américains plutôt que de faire un avion
avec la France et pour la prolongation
du l'hélicoptère de combat
franco-allemand le tigre ils ont décidé
d'acheter des Apaches et de couilles
d'arrêter le programme franco-allemand
ça fait beaucoup
pour notre industrie d'armement c'est
catastrophique de la France du coup
alors on a vu effectivement que Emmanuel
Macron a aussi essayé de se rapprocher
de la Grande-Bretagne avec ce projet de
communauté politique européenne
peut-être que le Royaume-Uni aurait un
rôle à jouer en particulier quelle est
la marge de manœuvre bon la France a
quand même toujours une marge de
manœuvre parce que même si une parent
pas du coup franco-allemand tout de même
économiquement on est quand même
toujours très lié même si cette
diversifié d'aller vers la Chine etc et
puis même si justement il refuse il
défendent leur intérêt refuse le tout
européen un moment ils sont quand même
toujours limités c'est un peu ce qu'on a
vu aussi avec le Royaume-Uni
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment on veut
toujours jouer cavalier seul on va voir
par la Chine on voit que la Chine leur
prend énormément de parts de marché et
énormément monter en gamme et donc
s'avère comme des concurrents qui vont
être de plus en plus importants donc là
tout d'un coup on retrouve ses
partenaires européens on se dit ah bah
tout d'un coup c'est pas mal de coopérer
et donc on l'a vu avec les batteries on
était complètement opposés puis tout
d'un coup c'était à Mama c'est les
batteries c'est vrai qu'on est
complètement dépendant la Chine donc on
va voir ça peut marcher aucun parka ça
fait marcher quand il y a une menace de
leurs intérêts par rapport au bloc et
étranger et c'est comme ça que le
l'Europe continuerait
Alexandre du jour on a construit
au niveau européen aux intérêts
nationaux reproche à l'Allemagne de
d'acheter américain au lieu d'acheter
européen le sous-titre
non pas du tout parce que depuis 10 ans
vous avez vraiment une accélération de
ces blocs au niveau économique
aujourd'hui vous regardez le plan de
relance américain il y a vous avez des
aides c'est la batterie ne vient pas de
Chine et si votre voiture est faite aux
États aux États-Unis donc on est dans un
protectionnisme agressif qui est avéré
que ce soit la Chine et quoi que ce soit
des États-Unis et donc c'est une
conséquence première pour que les
constructeurs automobiles européens et
donc forcément pour les Allemands donc
là attention ça ne va plus du tout on se
rappelle qu'on est européen et là en
effet on se dit il faut réindustrialiser
et être autonome sur ses constructions
sur sur ce nom on a besoin pour faire
des automobiles pour ne pas perdre ses
marchés donc là on devient européen et
ça ça sera de plus en plus agressif tous
les autres pays le font et nous on le
font on le fait pas donc c'est vrai que
l'Allemagne n'a pas encore à ce qu'on ne
le fait pas parce que l'Allemagne se dit
pour l'instant je peux encore jouer ma
carte et encore jouer cavalier seul
parce que j'ai justement encore du
pouvoir économique grâce avec ces gens
commerciaux et donc il faut que je joue
cette carte pour essayer de renforcer ma
puissance par rapport au pays baltes et
par rapport à leur Alexandre village il
y a même pas pu s'exprimer de cette
logique de blocs que vous décrivez c'est
que le seul moyen pour la France pour
l'Allemagne et pour l'Europe de
continuer à peser dans l'ordre
économique international c'est de s'unir
et d'arrêter de d'entretenir des petites
querelles et des tensions quand vous
devez refusé d'un comme vous l'avez dit
d'acheter tel ou tel matériel français
c'est pas du tout ce que pour les a
vraiment disponible ce matériel et
encore une fois que je mettrai pas les
États-Unis et la Chine sur le même
niveau nos capacités de production
notamment dans le domaine de défense
sont moins production c'est que c'est
c'est un moment regarder les chiffres
regarder les faits vous pouvez pas avoir
ce genre de discours et de dire ah bah
oui non pas acheter la les matériaux
français parce qu'on a peut-être pas la
capacité pourquoi ils ont pas pourquoi
ils ont pas acheté français mais pas du
tout mais c'est la carte
ils prennent sida de disponible de
meilleure qualité et de moins cher si on
réformé si on réorganiser nos capacités
de production dans le domaine de la
défense si on développait une offre qui
est plus compétitive et choisirait
d'acheter français concernant le F35 il
y a une désinformation complète le F35
qui s'inscrit dans une disposition très
claire du traité dans le cadre du
nucléaire cherisme seul les F35 qui
était en mesure de transporter
allemand pour
en cas d'utiliser la dissuasion c'est
inquiétant de sortir des trucs pas parce
que c'est pas vrai mais alors allez-y
argument c'est absolument pas j'ai même
pas argumenté c'est les Allemands ont
utilisé l'argument l'arme nucléaire pour
dire j'achète américain mais vous pouvez
parfaitement acheter des rafales qui
transportent aussi à la capacités
américaines
allemands faut pas dire faut pas dire ça
faut pas dire
l'industrie française c'est pas faire
des avions de combat
F35 c'est juste honnêtement pour revenir
au sujet parce qu'il nous reste cinq
minutes pierre Lelouch est-ce que on va
s'en sortir que vous allez recréer une
crédibilité vieillit de l'Allemagne ça
n'existe pas c'est un mythe ça n'a
jamais existé
madame ça a existait à un moment très
précis de l'après-guerre où il fallait
donner le signe de la réconciliation
dans des peuples qui s'étaient donc ça
n'existe entre la réunification c'est
quand même savoir il y avait on était
dans le pays d'Oradour-sur-Glane où ont
traité les Allemands de donc il fallait
se signal de réconciliation c'est ça qui
a permis la construction européenne mais
c'est une autre époque aujourd'hui on
est dans une phase de réinsertion de la
puissance allemande dans un
environnement géopolitique très
compliqué ils sont en train d'essayer
dans la ligne mesure de possible de
remettre leur lit de place sans trop
casser leurs voisins quand ils
s'aperçoivent qu'ils vont trop loin ils
reviennent en arrière parce que ils ont
besoin du chauffeur qui conduit une
Mercedes
que je n'ai pas évoqué qui est
fondamental c'est le contrôle qui exerce
l'Allemagne sur les institutions
européennes moi j'ai eu ça j'ai vécu
cela tous les groupes politiques du
Parlement européen sont tenus par
majoritairement par les Allemands tous
les secrétaires généraux des groupes
sont allemands à la Commission les
principales directions sont tenues par
les Allemands au Conseil
la machine européenne
on a eu un peu une vision de voilà
l'Allemagne a sauvé l'Europe a toujours
aidé l'Europe etc lorsque vous avez eu
la réunification vous en avez parlé
quand vous regardez les fonds à louer
par la Banque européenne
d'investissement et par les fonds
européens c'est c'est grâce à ses fonds
européens que vous avez eu c'est très
unification allemande donc je veux dire
eux aussi ont profité justement de
l'intégration européenne ce n'est pas
que les pays du Sud ce n'est pas
l'Italie ce n'est pas que les robinet
plutôt que de quoi aussi d'accuser
l'Allemagne en permanence de faire
cavalier seul ou d'être égoïste je pense
qu'on devrait s'inspirer d'elle pour
apprendre à défendre mieux nos intérêts
politiquesment au Parlement ou à
Bruxelles du point de vue industriel et
également et d'apprendre comme
l'Allemagne à mieux articuler nos
intérêts nationaux avec l'intérêt
général européen
ce que vous venez de dire je peux être
d'accord et je n'ai cessé de me battre
pour que notre pays se réindustrialise
qu'on est pas beaucoup plus proactive à
Bruxelles qu'on est le meilleur des
député qu'on a qu'on introduise des
Français à tous les échelons dans la
machine on le fait beaucoup moins bien
parce qu'on est pas très bon à ça en
France quant à la machine industrielle
française elle a été cassée par nous pas
par les Allemands là-dessus je vous
rejoins non mais attendez
ayant dit ce que nous sommes nous
responsables de l'état de la France
aujourd'hui ne change pas tout ce que
j'ai dit sur la stratégie de notre
principale voisin aujourd'hui hier et
avant-hier et si nous ne sommes pas
capables de voir ce qui est en train de
se passer vraiment dommage parce que on
est en train de changer d'Europe et
quand j'entends le président de la
République dire c'est l'Allemagne qui
s'isole je les bras m'en tombent parce
que aujourd'hui en Europe c'est la
France qui est isolée c'est pas
l'Allemagne tout le monde le
gouvernement
pourquoi donc en tout cas il n'y a pas
eu de conférence de presse après ce
fameux déjeuner merci d'avoir été avec
nous pierre Lelouch merci Alexandre
robinet Borgomano merci Anne-Sophie
alcif merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi vous restez avec nous surface 24
[Musique]